he's Adam Sandler who's kind enough to
join us playing her today yes and you
look great
you like it yeah you look good so Sam
comes in and I'm always interested to
see what he has on because chances are
it wasn't picked out it was a perfect
t-shirt before the accident so I said is
that toothpaste on yes you sure it and I
thought I got it out yeah I you want to
know how I tried to get it out not water
and her an Iraq that I saw that might
yes somewhere right yeah like there's
just a little off do you do household
chores
sometimes I pick up the dog mess and and
I will bring the dishes to the sink all
the way to the sink close to the sake
have you done a load of laundry in the
last five years I would not no no I
definitely I like I watch it when they
turn it on I watch it through the full
40 minutes spin that's fun but you don't
help out no I just encourage the people
nice work
but you grew up in New Hampshire aren't
you yes like a handyman can you be
electrical or I can I can I take an ice
pick out and help clear the driveway and
makes you know it was always terrible
growing up when you saw your father fall
on the ice that was that's when you were
watching from the window is yeah I used
to scream help him somebody helping dad
funny yeah but but a different kind he
wasn't like a goofball like me he was
just strong cool dude who when he talked
everybody would listen and he would he
would say very funny stuff and he would
tell stories
when did he acknowledge your humor he
always loved I like would get a kick out
of me but he was always nervous for me
he thought I would say he would say hey
don't be such a big mouth that kind of
stuff he want me to calm down
did you ever want to be a serious actor
no never even a thought and when the
fact that I do stuff like that is great
and I love doing it but it was not even
up when I went to NYU and I was studying
acting I was like what the hell am I
doing here
I don't because they're serious about
their Ivy Mary's NYU
I would get lost in every conversation
everybody was talking about playwrights
and who was in there anybody famous in
those classes ah
well Molly Shannon I loved her always
she was we were in school together and
and I a couple of other guys who I
wasn't tight with anybody but who became
like I'm I knew this guy Titus was a
great actor and he does a lot of good
stuff and I can't room I can't remember
anybody but your friends are comedians
yes we were all fond of like being funny
but you don't have us do you have a
friend who's a serious actor yeah
Buscemi look at me he can do it all and
he can be goofy too he can be goofy too
but no i yeah I know all those guys I've
done a you know Stiller likes he's
really into know he knows a lot of stuff
about serious acting and uh yeah I'm
friends with all these guys I can talk
to him and stuff but that was not my
path I didn't want to do that but when
you had Buscemi do the mr. deeds
character yeah yeah yeah yeah I love I
love he's he's the best at whatever he
does any time you were writing something
we say old man maybe we can make that
Buscemi it just relaxes you so much
because you know he'll he's gonna be
great in it you uh you rode in one your
Cadillac today Kevin James Cadillac I
come now explain this though because you
were very nice with people who have been
in a lot of your movies or and the bit
times no I didn't get a car from you you
do two more movies with me I'm gonna
guess your car so does that count with
the the movie that's coming out yes so
one one one more after this one more
more I guess your car what do I get
what do you want what do you like I'd
like to have this gotta be American
we've all there what about that
souped-up Dodge Hemi that you have don't
you have that yes I have the Challenger
and it's the the Hellcat how many
horsepowers them I forget it's a lot
right it's insane is it a thousand not
not a thousand but it's and it's a
number that you just go wow that's it
that's how I do you take it out yeah all
the time
at cruising that thing I just I go
really fast for a second and then I get
nervous and I calm down
have you ever once last time you got
pulled over I get pulled over us
sometimes and we have nice conversations
how does it work you know pretty pretty
good drives out pretty good I was
license registration and then you say
well it usually it goes like sir do you
know sad all right so you you get a
Kevin James buys you accounts he was
nice one day I come in the driveway and
or maybe no was on I was on the set I'm
a movie and then his buddy Gino said ace
might even had a bow on or something
cool like that and he said Kevin got you
a gift and it was a Cadillac and then KJ
said yeah you always do nice stuff for
everybody else I thought I would do
something nice for you and so I still
drive it that was like five years ago
but then you bought Spade Kevin James
all those guys that are back in the den
Chris Rock did get him an unamerican
Maseratis and stuff like that and then I
got a Tesla for Schneider because back
in the day he was he was always electric
he's been electrical long time okay and
then yeah and then but I have a funny
story about Spade guy so it's uh we're
at this nice new hotel here in town cuz
he he always says that I'm nice about
money and all that stuff so he we're
having this dinner and it's a Passover
dinner
I think it's Passover and we and that's
me and my family and my wife's family
and we're all eating there's literally
like 18 of us at a nice hotel having a
Passover I don't know why we're there
but we're at the Waldorf here in LA it's
a new wall door I think and that Spade
just coincidentally was there and we at
the end of the meal though I go to pay
in the way it says your friend already
took care of that I said he did why did
he do that and then he's like oh I don't
know but he paid for it and then I
called Spade up and I said buddy that
was nuts
that was a lot of people mommy goes well
you're always nice to us and blah blah
blah
then I said but that way you gotta hit
hard on that one man
and then the next day I talked to him
and he said his credit card company
called and said are you aware there was
a giant bill above us and he was he's
depressed was he trying to get out of it
he did no no he's good he's good with
this cash - is he Jewish
David Spade is not Jewish she didn't
know what Passover Oh buddy he just
enjoyed that all we were in there doing
the Kasatka and no no now we still
maintain that that show blackish took
they ripped off Fritzi
because Fritzi has been saying Jew he's
Jewish within the realms of Judea exact
did you hear about fritzy stand up what
do you make the Super Bowl he did he did
17 minutes of stand-up how did you do
that it's something I always wanted to
do and yeah pub in Minneapolis give
megive salmon a taste - yes please
now not the dirty stuff like he went
blue really yeah he's amazing
yes eaten and you know it's interesting
about it Todd was the headliner that
they of course of naturally and each
comic that got up before him was like
more more and more accomplished so you'd
be like hey you've seen this guy yet a
Comedy Central stand up and you've seen
them on The Tonight Show
oh here's Jimmy lip rehearsing what I
want to say and the sequence I want to
say it over and over again our head and
making sure what I say at the beginning
somehow ties around I'm sort of kind of
comes and then the comedian's before you
say stuff that oh there he is comedians
before you say stuff that might step on
you and you get nervous right there but
they're introducing these guys like seem
said he you saw him on Fallon and you
start out the gate with 17 minutes
unbelievable nobody does that's hard
nobody does more than five yes right
first time that's incredible do you
remember your first time you did yes
that you got paid got paid no I remember
my first open mic
at stitches in Boston and I was 1717
they hated me and that but I loved you
like my brother Scott drove me down from
New Hampshire to Boston I went on and I
didn't boo me because I was so young and
they felt bad for me and I had braces
and somehow more like better that you
had a retainer the braces was progress
my teeth were almost yeah but I remember
you said to me I would you wanted to
write 15 minutes to stand up for me to
do something at the improv this is years
ago you Danny
you'd be incredible no yes I don't think
so
guarantee you were destroyed she was
better she was you have the timing down
in the stick and you're confident guy
but fritzy was really good really man
what did you talk about family stuff
yeah I talked about my neurotic mother
and we were going to Israel and then
nine days before we were going to the
trip
that's when Trump decided he's good he
said that the capital of Israel he told
me that when I get on the plane make
sure I go find the pilot and making
promises gonna be no turbulence I don't
know how much gas to put in the plane
what if you run at a guess you can't
stop at a gas station while you're
flying space there she was just
absolutely funny yeah that's cool
congratulations
so we're gonna try to get him maybe at
Caroline's in New York I open mic like a
middle middle you can middle with that
much time that's a lot okay did you ever
follow rock onstage yeah yeah we used to
go how tough back in the day we were
both young and we both had holes in our
act so it didn't matter but when did now
okay but what changed with rock that and
you don't do as much stand up and rock
does you no it's still do you know what
I've been I've been running around now
and I'm actually I'm doing a special and
that's looks special Oh was I supposed
to mention now nope I just I've been
doing it running around for a couple
years now it's called the week of it'll
be on Netflix
dad April 2 well no yeah that's our
movie we'll stop yelling
Chris Wragge you're in me no I you
understand it yeah I'm in now that's the
baseball movie yeah you're you you do a
scene with my daughter okay any so
that's April 22nd that's a whole other
thing but me I'm doing a stand-up
special that I'm running around doing
doing gigs and stuff
okay The Sandman is also on a comedy
tour and filming it for Netflix special
yeah yeah yeah okay but but um Rock
actually he left SNL and and he was
determined to become the best stand-up
and he did and he just wrote and wrote
and wrote and then he did that first HBO
special and then everybody since says
nobody's touched him since yeah I don't
know anybody any comedian that's done
stand-up in an hour and put a special
that has said I think it's better than
rocks they're always like well no rock
is rock and then there's me and and yeah
he's definitely crushed it Kevin James
stand-up special is incredible by the
way I just really it's unbelievable it's
coming out I think soon so and we're
back to being friends again you okay
Jack yeah what happened November when we
did chuck and Larry yeah and you guys
weren't friends first no because I came
in and he was like a jilted lover
because then we went to play basketball
you remember that and then he was I said
to Sandman
because we're doing so we're doing my
scene and then I remember Kevin James go
how about I take a break and we'll come
back and talk about this visit ease is
what it's a 14 after the hour back with
more with Adam Sandler after this and
the Dan Patrick show the damage just
found out they made the final cut you're
in you like make a beautiful shot it's
woop sin and the four of you walk
Beatles esque into the into the Little
League field and the crowd crowd loves
it it's called the week of and you can
see it on Netflix starting it's good The
Sandman also in a comedy tour filming
for a Netflix special yeah prior to the
break I mentioned Kevin James we were
doing and now pronounce you chuck and
Larry yes and I come in soon as I get
there
Sandman goes hey let's go play
basketball right and then I could see
that Kevin James had a sad look on his
face because I had just taken you from
him well from his arms he didn't know
our history he did not sure come up and
he didn't play basketball he by the way
when he goes on the bass one horton
place it's dangerous yeah he looks like
he could hurt you he goes after like
loose balls and goes Full Tilt and
knocks people over he's too strong so we
we go play basketball then we come back
and then we're gonna do my scene and
it's a small scene where I'm a police
officer so right before we start Kevin
James like there's a little bit of
tension friction
honestly like I could just tell that he
was not pleased with me because usually
a Kevin James mood he gets moody okay
but I think that he was in competition
for you know Sandler's love with me and
I already had Sandler's Lum so I didn't
I didn't need that
waterboy love yes and then he says hey
why don't you do can you do a Brooklyn
accent like a total and one that was
kind of a jerky my I think he was he
might have come across that way okay he
was trying to bring you to a place you
haven't been before no no no no no let's
don't do that because I he could have
told me that prior to Kevin James is a
fine human being who in his own way was
pulled out of that performance out of
you did you see how good you were in the
moment I didn't do a Brooklyn accent yes
but he made sure you did didn't in his
own way cuz you weren't ready for this I
was not ready for that and then I think
he wanted to embarrass me by saying uh
you know be better if you don't like a
Brooklyn accent and then I went and then
I looked at you like really no no okay
that's how it happened that's how it
happened you were wondering what we were
laughing at when you walk astute okay
I was wrestling I heard yeah a lotta
right so this is this is a fan who is
yes but it's like a wrestling fan fest
at a local high school and like I think
Terry Funk in a Diamond Dallas Page and
some older wrestlers they're signing
autographs and they're taking questions
from fans in the stands and this is how
it sounded okay next question Jeff where
are you right there yeah I just want to
thank each and every one help
or all you've done it's still real to me
damn it
well he was he was a young kid to be
unknown that the the history of
wrestling Limpy didn't he got emotional
and I thought it was a good moment for
that guy that's nice that's he I why you
know who I saw in Manchester New
Hampshire as a youth with my brother and
my father Andre the Giant Andre the
Giant fought Fuji and Tanaka old were
you I was probably like eight and and in
New Hampshire between matches guys from
New Hampshire were jumping in the ring
and fighting in the crowd was the best
who Tanaka though and the Grand Wizard
was there but did you you thought it was
serious back then no no my father told
me the whole time but we watched it
every week oh we didn't care that it was
fake and and we loved it then my father
was like really funny with wrestling
like he would laugh his head off and say
come on and he loved Bruno Sammartino we
all vote for Bruno now you you're not a
softy though you don't cry easily do I
saw a rich cried at the muppet yeah yeah
yeah like you wouldn't do that I get
teary-eyed yes my kids always say I
never seen you cry I want to see what
you look like when they scream that
weight you don't cry you don't cry I
don't cry that much now what would make
you cry yes real real stuff I get you
know my father
I get the Knicks won the title ah no
that would make no no no I'd be baffled
but Yankees no none of that stuff makes
me teary-eyed
I'm happy like when I see a sports story
where a you know guys visiting a kid
who's sick and bring some joy that
always makes me cry yeah that's you've
had to cry in a movie though heaven yes
a lot I've done like five times where I
had to go full-on crying it's not easy
for me I have to who's the best you've
ever been around the kitronik you Winona
Ryder Winona Ryder in deeds literally
said we had her cry in the scene and
then she does the first take and she's
crying never was like holy cow that was
insane she just cried full-on what the
how do you do that and then they said
the camera operators mentioned something
like you know I'm pushing in I don't get
there in time for the first year and so
they said to her can you start to cry
and they gave her a word she goes okay
and then waited like bugs a sentence or
two of then all of a sudden boom bawling
crying says it does she was that was not
I don't know how that how do you do that
I love deeds me too because John
Turturro is so great in there and
Buscemi's great in there yes I thought
and I thought Winona was great yeah but
I think that's when I first met you you
were shooting the scene where she gets
robbed or heating up yeah by covert yes
when I give covert that's right we were
vibrato fella yes and I we stopped by
your trailer and you were sleeping and
you had to get up and I remember you got
up and my I brought my kids in there
that's right I remember that all of them
yeah Braham is new there might have been
kids who weren't my kids but when we
went in there and you had your Bulldog I
kept that sad monster
yes that was monster Watson and meatball
in my house back then excuse me yes yes
and by the way I saw your daughter and I
told you she's is the best Georgia
she's so cute who was your favorite
comedian growing up when I was little I
used to listen to old albums I liked
Shelley Berman and I liked Cosby and I
liked Keyshia Chang and
and Rodney then Rodney my father got me
no respect I thinking and then Rodney
was that's all we did was Rodney jokes
around there but you also and I think
I've asked you this I've known you a
long time the Happy Hanukkah song yes
that I've asked you to perform that and
yeah but you never do it I don't
it's not like I'm holding back from
doing I just don't know I don't remember
every word of it but I said I would get
you the words and even give you a guitar
well yeah let's do a next Annika
come on and sing it right and I got to
write a new one though you guys a couple
you guys can get in that way like the
2018 Happy Hanukkah be fruits also that
would be yeah no now mclubbe it's
partially Jewish that's fine that's like
Rod Carew right yes yes both seat and I
will convert for a week to be in it with
you and then go back when we conversion
you know in that conversion you could
get beaten so many times don't do it but
you but do you like performing like
museum i honest to god my mice know
you're on Fallon weren't you recently in
you did you sing that was a repeat I
think oh yeah so with with Miley Cyrus
yes yes yes I was just singing normal I
was I wasn't it was fun I love doing it
and I when I do my tours now I mean no
kidding my shows are really long I do
like an hour 45 or something something
like that and so we do a lot of songs
and a lot of it's all comedy songs and
stand-up and I'd I love singing the
songs the most feel the most relaxed
what about that song bad play date yes
that's goes over nice it does yes yes
it's a song about that talk about a kid
that's terrorizing the house when you
your kid has a friend over and then what
do you do I get even at the end do
what's my next movie if this one's
coming out at the end of April I think
the one that gets me a car Wow so this
is gonna be an expensive movie for me I
I'm putting together movie now with your
old Coast co-star Jen Aniston no and
we're shooting in a place
this isn't you know I was starting the
whole process right now is this gonna be
Hawaii again you're gonna be upset
Montreal and Italy can you make it won't
take Italy yes guys I don't know if you
got it in vine let me get back then yeah
I'll try to get you guys a package deal
I can get you guys all cars to our you
just got it you got another four or five
movies for you guys I think I'm up to
sixteen sometimes more than everybody
right it's a lot you win
yeah I'll get you a car I just you got
to think about what it should be okay
and and how am i doing in the brackets
by this oh I don't know McLovin tied for
first I thought so yeah you you asked uh
Arizona sandy San Diego State no uh
South Dakota State is he tied with me
yep you both have 14 out of 16 Danny mmm
my you know who picked him within my
daughter say to yesterday she was sick
from school and I woke her up that we
got into this bracket what's a bracket
and she wrote she wrote hello to Danny
on the on me I love that that she was my
co-star in a couple of my scenes that he
loves that you you know I still go back
I was angry at you when I did the movie
with Aniston and Kidman because there
was no there was no dialogue in the
script for me I had so much fun
I was ultimately ultimately I did but
when I went out on stage because I play
this nightclub owner and I have an
estate in Kidman yes Dave Matthews and
you are in this in the audience good
friend of yours and yelling and I
stopped and then you go Danny
Danny had lib oh that's right yeah and I
went so I have like Kidman is really
serious like she's an actress yes I can
Astin was a whole lot of fun like no
Kidman had the lightness they were all
pulling for you now you're gonna have to
ad-lib in Italian if you do this next
movie if you come to Italy
you got to work up Wow look at that
Aniston yeah that was magic that was the
best yeah that was fun she was great
yeah but you didn't you missed this
scene um when when they did the belly
dancing kid
min is up there belly dancing and
Aniston doesn't realize how good Kidman
is yeah and she says under her breath
you got to be bleep in kidding me oh and
then she called you up and then you go
no play it play it comedy but like play
it up like you know Carol Burnett type
fun which is how she did it and she did
a great job but he looked good too
though when Kidman came up there and was
ripped she had like a a nine pack and
she had just had a baby and you could
see Aniston going you gotta be kidding I
gotta follow that yeah it was like when
you were doing stand-up and you had to
follow the guy who was on Jimmy Fallon
yeah shook you up ridiculous
and now you know Jennifer's on the
rebound so you know this trip to Italy
let's not make it about that
okay you're right you said I I finally
got a makeout scene yes and it was with
the the woman from the Goldbergs that's
right yeah yeah but it wasn't in the
script yeah do you remember that how
awkward that was yeah I
we're doing rehearsal and then Sandman
goes so my daughter is working on the
movie with us she's there and she's
watching the scene and we're just
worried we're rehearsing the line so
Drew Barrymore's there in Sandman's
there and then this time it goes Danny
kisser I just met her like 15 minutes
earlier you brought her some luck on the
Goldbergs yes Coby Wendy Wendy Wendy
mclendon-covey and very very funny very
talented yeah but and then my daughter
sees me kiss this woman oh yeah okay so
we got done with the take and she goes
are you gonna tell mom yes I'm gonna
tell her and she goes okay I won't tell
her I said no I'll tell her because I
didn't know it wasn't in this great
mouth closed yes no it wasn't what you
got yeah
[Laughter]
are you a Rams fan now are you a charger
fan do you care Jared Jared you're your
nephew no Jerry the quarter oh look you
have a nephew named Jared yes both the
Jer but Jared I got a friend of mine
works for the Rams Michael Bennett hey
he and he called me up and said that
Jared liked The Longest Yard and he
signed a signed a Rams shirt his shirt
that he used when they played Seattle
which I told my kids they were excited
they smelled the shirt and everything
but he signed a share for me and they
asked if I would sign his Mean Machine
shirt so I did that just yesterday oh
nice yes so I gotta go meet that man
he's a friend of the show he's a studdy
yeah and uh we got the jersey from the
texans game yep oh is that did they win
that one too
I'm gonna go yeah he said after win
after yeah yeah yeah he said he would
give us one after one and then beat the
tech so you're Rams man well no I mean I
can't say that I but I definitely
anybody who's who's uh becomes a
personal friend of mine on polar form so
yeah IIIi and I was happy for the Rams
this year that was great yeah well are
you Lake
how many liquor games you've been do it
one reason I haven't been much this year
now do you have seats or I just get up
you know I can how does that work cuz
you even I know I just call up somebody
and they they sand sand man it that's it
they go here you go Sam it but I go with
Jack if I go iko iko I your Mac invites
me and I go to I just haven't owned it
houses yeah Mac Nicholson and then uh
and I do basketball it's been rough this
year I don't know I don't know his
Nicholson retired from acting I don't
know I don't know he's funny still off
yeah he's funny and happy what do you do
like if you hang with Nicholson like
what is that like
yes great great you tell stories and
these and a great moon he's smart as
hell knows everything
recent full paper every day he really is
bananas smart would would he allow you
to do a documentary
shoot a document home he was not a
private man I don't think he would but
do you know what he's got a lot of
stories crazy Yankee fan - well we grew
up in Jersey yes yeah yes when you like
to be she used to say ya know I'd have
more problems but uh but I'll tell you
what I'm he in the beginning when I used
to started hanging with him uh he would
always say come over yourself like the
lady I can't do it I can't do it I can't
I'm not allowed to do that and he'd
always be like I had that too and then I
just was so happy to be said he grew up
a Knicks fan and then became a Laker fan
he was you know probably nicked
something on the East Coast and then and
then he said he got he said he bought
season tickets with his buddy and he
used to sit out up in the bleachers I
think and when he first first moved out
and he said and I just allowed myself to
enjoy the lake you know III gotta tell
ya I could like the Lakers now they
don't bother me like it doesn't bother
as much I'm slowly becoming okay with it
if LeBron came to the Lakers yeah that'd
be fun you'd be okay with them
III would be happy for the town would
you buy season tickets no I don't need
them oh that's right
you just call and say it's Sam I just
whisper Sandman in the phone does your
wife call you Sandman I know yeah okay
if she says Adam like what what does Jen
call me Adam either she calls me to hear
weird nicknames for me like no nay I
don't know how it happened but she calls
me known a known a not noni no no knee
no well she's mad justice they're just
there okay that's it yeah yeah but
you're not in trouble ever yeah yeah you
know I can get but you don't drink you
don't get in trouble you don't stay out
like well do that you could get in
trouble I have my own ways household
being hated for moments that affect the
movie is the week of starring myself and
the dance and cameos with Adam Sandler
and Chris Rock
it's April 27th so I'll Netflix you just
if you have Netflix you just go to
Netflix and then the movies there's a
good movie
is there a premiere yeah in New York oh
you guys can come but wait why are you
bearing the lead here what do you mean
that's great we didn't know about it we
were just putting it together now it's
it's like the week of the movie I'm like
I'm doing my special in Newark Newark
then I come to uh then I come to
Manhattan and then well you guys could
all come but we'll have like a few days
are hanging out yeah I'll just check
what the guys were completely available
it'll be good and bring the families and
so that's it's the week of April 27th
the rock very funny in it he plays plays
a wealthy LA doctor who comes through I
live in Long Island on Long Island not
e'en on on Long you know someone's not
from Long Island they say in Laura
that's a mistake
and then he dates your daughter not
Chris Chris's son is marrying my
daughter I'd okay so you two may be at
loggerheads we we it's just the week of
the wedding and the preparation and
stuff and Robert Smigel directed it and
we wrote it together and you know
Roberts mom yes very funny funny genius
man and it's pretty pretty great and as
a and my uncle Seymour I'm carrying my
uncle Seymour in that scene
Jim Barone and he is excellent in the
movie he's funny as hell and I love you
buddy if you're listening the week of
and on Netflix beginning April 27th
Sandman who's winning who do you have
winning the elenova uh yeah what I know
great they're gonna win it aren't they I
picked Duke anyone else picked up a few
a lot more Villanova's but do kill it
they're good they're just two guys again
well it's about guard play yeah I got
Virginia going even though they lost the
six-man I got Virginia going deep well
that was a what do you guys feel about
that
you know why I did that because Sadie
said to me are you playing in Virginia
and if one of my concerts is in
I said yes she said you should be nice
and feminine you're right hmm so you got
a go with you that could be the opening
line when you do your stand-up back
there yes yeah thank you do you want to
shoot some baskets on the way up
yes I got a I got a hoop out there I'm
nervous about my toothpaste thing I just
don't want to get sweat on it and you
got one of our t-shirts but yes now can
you put that on instead I hope that
you're gonna be able to wear that and
you know display you Paulie gave
Sandman the shirt off his back exhale
launder it thank you I will not I don't
need to I know your yours your hygiene
is excellent The Sandman is on Comedy
Tour filming at for Netflix all right
we're back to close up shop here in Los
Angeles and I'm se out here everybody
will go out and shoot some hoops here
with the Sandman Devils Sandman this
year go-to shot so good did you like the
a tour I can't gauge the basket where
I'm at all right [ __ ] they call him
bucket one more markets boom there it is
Pauly do you have your mic go to is I
pick up my dribble and I get it over to
somebody that's it see ya I'm a deep
threat oh that's right yeah what's your
go-to
I just muscled them down
[Laughter]
we should leave this out I know I'm
supposed to have I have this two-hand
thing I don't know how it happened but
you can shoot but boo boo Richard should
try to change it for them and make it
good but who couldn't shoot ya know we
cool so is it a set shot
oh that's too deep you should know I
shoot I shoot I like moving a little
late beer step into it
I can I can get it going but I gotta
take it it's got a little that's old for
everything it is a little and there we
go under the weather - and your that's
better this is your shots right in I
thought on the radio about 30 okay yeah
Mike over in here and over there those
are your shot hoops with the Sandman out
there he saw our game we're pretty
pretty impressive
all of us played beautifully yeah buddy
hit Brett see you in the lefty hook is
the craziest but he can't go pretty
can't go right so he goes left and
shoots the hook by left hand to the
right we have some meat on this did you
you don't eat that kind of stuff I can
eat it it's early I am what if it's
sausage it's wrapped in around a muffin
yeah that doesn't make sense it's Pauly
you got the detail it's a blueberry
muffin with wrapped in sausage and bacon
it's great at 9 a.m.
hold up yeah we did it on the tray girl
by the way yeah yeah it's good did we
had um who do we have on yes Josh
Duhamel and he did karaoke yes are you a
karaoke guy I never do it I mean I've
been around that I never jump in no you
I I didn't know why no like I did it
once at dimples in Burbank oh yeah now
when Alice that's been around man now
it's not there anymore oh is that right
yeah I think they do something but Wow
Paulie took me to dimples I don't know
how many years ago like oh four and I
did Elvis in the ghetto in the news mama
cried oh yeah yeah and the ladies loved
that too of course yeah that's when you
were trying to woo another woman
no the Harris Hilton was there they're
really Paris Hilton or Britney Spears
was there that night point dimples was
rocking for a while but I was there
before was a hip joint mine I lived out
in the valley and dimples we used to go
by there just listen listen him hear you
when he gives you as the snow flies on a
cold and gray Chicago more you know like
what no Elvis right
I don't think Elvis throat any of his
songs I think he knocked out a few do
you think I think I don't think so I'll
tell you one thing if he was still alive
you would have him in one of your movies
with who do you want to have as a cameo
like who hasn't been in the movie
because the Hawaii this guy Elvis we're
going to Hawaii again how about you
remake blue Hawaii I would love to I
would love to do any anything that that
Elvis did that before
I loved Elvis do it like Zac Efron plays
Elvis haha yeah yeah yeah and you're
like his man you could beat Colonel Tom
Parker on that old now I can't do the
Elvis thing yeah I've got to be the
manager of Elvis's in no way man I'm
still Elvis
I got loose hips man did you ever talk
to Justin Timberlake when with the
Jessica Biel scene and chuck and Larry
no like that would never come up no but
I did know Justin Timberlake Oh
Ben Stiller showed me a long time ago
when we were our first my first time I
went to the Super Bowl we talked to in
sync and and we did a skit with them
maybe someday you can show that we were
funny together
you and Tim Burling well was all all to
get all the fellas I think we had a
dance-off oh no we were teaching them
how to dance
me and still it oh yeah and and yeah
please look at that one day well you did
the meyerwitz
what still you know with was Stiller yes
and you were serious stuff did you see
it yes I did I told you yeah you said I
was very good thank you yeah
they compliment but do you know when
somebody's telling you the truth if yeah
if you did a good really I would your
wife be honest with you have it people
who feel that they have to be honest
because they probably said so many mean
things about you to their wife or
something and their wife's at the party
with them so you see them at the party
and you say hi and they say hello and
someone brings up something you did in
front of them and they just keep staring
because they say in their head I have to
continue being nasty to this guy because
my wife will call me on it if I don't
you just feel it and those are the guys
I say yeah that guy doesn't like there
are people who don't like you there's
one well honestly if I have the same
percentage wise people who don't like me
at a party one out of six seven thousand
mm-hmm really no Seth Rogen doesn't like
you does yeah he's fine no he's good
he's good
oh say man thank you again for stopping
by love ya Klan hurt have it yeah thank
you
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]